.
THEY'VE ALREADY BROUGHT SIX
CASES.
>>> A U.S. CAPITOL POLICE
OFFICER BADLY BEATEN DURING THE
CAPITOL INSURRECTION IS HANDING
IN HIS BADGE.
SERGEANT AQUILINO GONELL SAYS
HIS LAST DAY ON THE JOB WILL BE
THIS SATURDAY WRITING IN A
LETTER TO HIS POLICE CHIEF,
"HAVING TO RETURN TO THE SCENE
OF THE CRIME EVERY DAY HAS
BECOME TAXING, UNBEARABLE, AND
NOT CONDUCIVE TO HEALING."
WE'RE HONORED TO HAVE OFFICER
AQUILINO GONELL WITH US IN
STUDIO SINCE ANNOUNCING HIS
RESIGNATION.
HOW DOES IT FEEL TO BE LEAVING A
JOB YOU FELT PASSIONATELY ABOUT
TAKING IN THE FIRST PLACE?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
IT'S TOUGH MAKING THAT DECISION
AFTER, YOU KNOW, 16 YEARS,
ALMOST HALF OF MY LIFE, HAD
DEDICATED TO BE A PUBLIC SERVANT
BOTH IN THE MILITARY AND ALSO AS
A POLICE OFFICER.
AND I'M NOT LEAVING BECAUSE OF
MY OWN ACCORD BUT BECAUSE THEY
DID THAT TO ME, THE MOB, AND THE
PEOPLE WHO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> BECAUSE YOUR INJURIES WERE SO
BAD THAT YOU COULDN'T DO YOUR
JOB ANYMORE AND ALSO --
>> THE PTSD, THE RANGE OF
MOTIONS ON MY SHOULDER.
I'M ABLE TO DO A LOT OF THINGS
WITH MY ARM, BUT I STILL HAVE
SOME LIMITATION ON IT, SO AS A
CIVILIAN, I COULD AFFORD -- I
COULD HAVE THE LUXURY TO WALK
AWAY FROM THAT ALTERCATION OR --
IF IT BECOMES VIOLENT OR NOT AS
A POLICE OFFICER, I CANNOT DO
THAT.
>> WITH THE LAST STRAW, WAS IT
THAT SOMEBODY TAPED A PHOTOGRAPH
OF DONALD TRUMP TO YOUR WORK
COMPUTER?
WAS THAT JUST THE FINAL STRAW?
>> YEAH.
ROUGHLY ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO --
NORMALLY I WATCH SOME OF THE
VIDEOS IN RELATION TO DOING
INVESTIGATION OR WRITING REPORTS
OR TESTIMONY FOR COURT, AND I
GUESS SOME PEOPLE THOUGHT I WAS
JUST OBSESSING ABOUT IT, BUT NOT
KNOWING THAT I WAS NOT WORKING
FOR THE COURT AND CONTINUING MY
WORK AS A POLICE OFFICER, AND I
TOOK A COUPLE DAYS OFF, AND WHEN
I CAME BACK, THERE WAS A PICTURE
OF DONALD TRUMP TAPED TO MY
COMPUTER SCREEN.
>> DO YOU THINK IT WAS SOMEBODY
JOKING AROUND, SOMEBODY BEING A
JERK, SOMEBODY TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE YOU?
WHAT'S YOUR INTERPRETATION?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA, BUT I DID --
FIRST I CRUMBLED IT, PUT IT IN
THE TRASH.
BUT THEN I SAID TO MYSELF, NO, I
CAN'T ALLOW THAT HAPPEN BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO ENTICE THEM TO
DO IT AGAIN.
SO I REACH OUT TO -- I SCANNED
AND SENT IT TO THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND AND SAID THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND VERY
INSENSITIVE OF WHOEVER DID IT,
WHETHER THEY DID IT JESTING OR
NOT.
>> RIGHT, BECAUSE YOU HOLD
DONALD TRUMP RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
RIOT.
THAT'S THE POINT THEY WERE
TRYING TO GET AT.
>> I GUESS.
I GUESS.
>> SPEAKING OF JANUARY 6th,
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE, SHE'S
BEEN DOWNPLAYING THE RIOT SINCE
IT HAPPENED.
LAST WEEKEND SHE WENT TO AN
EVENT, A NEW YORK REPUBLICAN
FUND-RAISER, AND SHE SAID THAT
IF SHE HAD LET THE ATTACK, IF
SHE HAD BEEN IN CHARGE OF IT,
THEY WOULD HAVE, QUOTE, WON.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IF WE HAD ORGANIZED THAT, WE
WOULD HAVE WON.
>> WHOOO!
>> THAT'S MISSION THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN ON.
>> SHE LATER SAID SHE WAS
JOKING, BUT JUST TO READ THAT
QUOTE, IF STEVE BANNON AND I HAD
ORGANIZED THAT, WE WOULD HAVE
WON, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN OURS.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE WHEN YOU
HEAR A CONGRESSWOMAN SAY THAT?
>> THAT'S COMING FROM THE SAME
PERSON THAT WHEN I WAS GIVING MY
TESTIMONY ON JULY LAST YEAR, SHE
WAS IN FRONT OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FIGHTING FOR THE
PATRIOTS BECAUSE --
>> THE PEOPLE WHO --
>> THE PEOPLE WHO HAD BEEN
ARRESTED.
AND THAT'S THE KIND OF SUPPORT
SHE THINKS THAT WE NEED.
AND THE WAY I TAKE IT IS THAT
BASED ON HER COMMENTS AND HER
ACTIONS, WE WERE -- THE POLICE
OFFICERS WERE THE BAD GUYS, NOT
THE OTHER WAY AROUND, WHICH IS
KIND OF CRAZY BECAUSE --
>> SHE'S NOT ALONE, THOUGH.
THAT'S DONALD TRUMP'S RESPONSE
TOO.
I HEARD WHEN YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES TESTIFIED PEOPLE ON
FOX WERE MAKING FUN OF YOU.
>> I MEAN, WHEN YOU -- IF YOU
TAKE THE WHOLE INCIDENT OF
JANUARY 6th AND YOU TAKE IT AT
THEIR OWN HOUSE OR A COURTHOUSE,
WOULDN'T THEY WANT PEOPLE TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
AND WOULDN'T THEY WANT THE
POLICE OFFICERS TO TAKE ACTIONS
AND PREVENT THEIR OWN FAMILY
MEMBERS FROM BEING ATTACKED?
BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED.
THE ATTACK AT THE CAPITOL
HAPPENED TO THEM, AND HAD IT NOT
BEEN FOR THE ACTIONS THAT MYSELF
AND MY COLLEAGUES, ALONG WITH
THE OTHER AGENCIES THAT CAME TO
SUPPORT US, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
BLOODBATH.
THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY MIND.
>> OF COURSE.
YOU GUYS ARE HEROES, YEAH.
>> IN THEIR MIND, WE WERE THE
BAD -- THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
STORMING THE CAPITOL, WHICH IS
RIDICULOUS.
WE WERE THERE DOING OUR JOB, AND
HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR OUR ACTIONS,
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
SENATORS, INCLUDING OFFICERS WHO
WOULD HAVE BEEN DEAD THAT DAY.
>> YOU THINK THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN KILLED.
>> YES.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE SAYING TO
ME AT THE POLICE LINE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO NOW?
>> I JUST COMPLETED A BOOK.
I TURNED IT IN TODAY.
IT'S CALLED "THE AMERICAN
TREASON."
THAT'S WHERE I'M FOCUSING NOW ON
HEALING FROM MY INJURIES AND
TAKING -- BEGINNIN